-The theme of the costume is
like, a doll house
that when you turn to the side
is a haunted house.
-Ooh!
-Yeah.
-So from the front,
it's like everything's fine,
and then it's like...
♪♪ Na, na, na na, na ♪♪
-[ Laughs ]
Exactly.
-This is a great place to play
or die.
[ Laughter ]
-Welcome back to "Late Night."
That was a clip
from "Making It."
What a nice world
you've built for yourself
that you and Nick Offerman
continue to get
to work together.
-Totally. He is my --
He's one of my work friends.
-Yeah. Top 20?
-He's one of my top 20
work friends.
-Yeah.
-And I love working with him
We don't talk about
anything personal.
We keep that separate.
-Just to the crafting.
-Yeah.
-I remember the first time
I met Nick was at a UCB show
where he came out
and did monologues and talke
about he was an actor
but he also, like,
built his own canoes.
-Yeah.
-He's just -- He then became
a very good fictional versio
of who he was in real life
-I've said this before.
He's certainly someone
I would go to when --
if, like, the end of the world
is happening.
He would know
how to do a lot of things.
-He'd be a good
"I Am Legend" person.
-He would.
-I feel like he would know
right away, if I said, "What
would you do in New York?"
he would have
like 50 things right away.
-He would. He'd know how
to build and run and fight
-Like, clean water.
-Yep.
-Like, I feel like
that would be a thing.
I fell like, even with all
the bottled water in New York,
I'd run out right away.
[ Laughter ]
And be like -- I'd be, like,
drinking my own pee.
And then one other person
would show up and be like,
"There's, like --
The water's right there.
You drank every --
-"Did you try anyone's houses?
[ Laughter ]
-And then
I'd still finish my pee.
I'd be like, "You're right
I should do that."
-It makes me think you want --
[ Laughter ]
-I mean, what am I gonna do,
throw it out?
[ Laughter ]
Shoemaker shared something
yesterday with us.
He e-mailed
a photo of this to us,
that 20 years ago, yesterday
you and I auditioned for "SNL.
And it's a list...
-Wild.
-...of all the names.
I don't really want
to show all the names because,
you know,
it's very personal
for everybody who was here
And, obviously,
for us, it was incredible.
But I mean,
some of these names are --
-I mean...Natalie Merchant
-Do you remember that
Natalie Merchant auditioned?
-Can you --
Look -- Boy George.
-Boy George, he was great.
-And Natalie Merchant.
-And he had
really good characters.
All the --
Boy George was so good,
'cause you thought like,
"Oh, he's gonna do songs,"
and he didn't do any songs
He just did characters.
-Dramatic characters.
-Daniel Day-Lewis.
Do you remember how nervou
Daniel Day-Lewis was?
-He was shaking.
-Yeah.
-And he's like, "Can I go over
my stuff with you?"
-He was needy.
Like, he wanted to go over it.
-And I was like,
"Is the last name 'Day'
or is the last name 'Lewis'?
You know what I mean?
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
-But he was so nice.
-He was so nice.
And I remember his audition.
Remember? He did all --
Because this is 2001.
He did all
the "Friends" characters.
[ Laughter ]
And they were,
like, really good.
-His Monica was insane.
-So good.
I was like, "What's a Monica?"
And he was like, "It's that.
-I can't even do it now.
-Yeah.
-'Cause, like, I remember,
like, he was --
I mean, we all have --
-We all had our Chandlers.
-Yeah.
-We all had our Ross's.
-But he did a Monica,
and we were like, "Whoa."
-"Wait. Is she in the room?"
He's so good.
I do remember his audition
taking a really long time,
though, 'cause he had to prepare
months for each character.
-Yes.
-So...
-Well, he would like --
He did a Chandler,
and then he said,
"I'll be back in an hour,"
to get into Joey.
-Yeah.
-And then he came back, and it
was like Matt LeBlanc walked in.
-It was like Joey came in.
Yeah.
He should have gotten it.
-But do you remember afterwards,
he's like, "We should
all meet for a drink"?
-Mm-hmm.
-'Cause we all went
through this, and then totally
like, he just didn't show.
-Well, you know what's
really interesting?
-What?
-Later on, a bartender
served us a drink and
was wearing the same bracele
as Daniel Day-Lewis.
[ Laughter ]
So...
And I remember clocking him an
being like, "That's so weird."
That guy's --
Oh, well."
You know,
I didn't even think about it
And then, a day after,
I was like, "He did show up.
-He did show up!
And he was the bartender.
-Yeah.
-Oh, my God.
-Probably a bartender
from "Friends" or something.
-Oh, yeah.
He was Gunther.
-He was Gunther.
[ Laughter ]
-God dammit, he's so good!
-So good.
I don't know
how he didn't get it.
-Yeah.
-I don't know how we did.
-I do think it would've been -
I don't know if, like,
Lorne and Daniel Day-Lewis
would have, like, worked.
-Mm-hmm.
-You know?
Yeah, that would --
-'Cause I feel like Lorne is
like, non-confrontational,
so if he would have said to,
like, someone else, like,
"Can you tell Daniel Day
he needs to get from that sketch
to that sketch in 30 seconds?"
-"Does Daniel Day want to take
all Daniel Day to get to his..."
[ Laughter ]
You know, it would be like that.
-That's a Lorne line.
Because Lorne famously
would make funny jokes
based on people's names.
-Oh, loved it.
So, he'd be like,
"Does he take
all Daniel Day to get to set?"
You know, stuff like that.
Um...
[ Laughter ]
But, yeah, Danny --
But you know what?
He was going by --
Now that I remember,
he was going by Danny Lewis.
And you were going by Seth -
you used
to spell your name M-Y-E-R-Z-Z
-Yeah.
-Myerzz.
-Yeah, and then Lorne said
I to change it
'cause it sounded
to outer space.
-Yeah, he was like --
He said it was wacky.
-[ Laughs ]
-Is what he said.
-That's another very common...
-He said you were like
a member of the Wack Pack,
is what he said.
-Yeah. He's so good
with those little things.
Like, Wack Pack
or "Take all Daniel Day."
-Yeah, yeah, what a giggler.
[ Laughter ]
But, yeah.
I mean do you have any --
I'm sure you have memories of --
I can't believe
that was 20 years ago.
I'm having --
-And by the way, I should note
this is the first time
on this show that I have eve
talked about
that I was on "SNL."
[ Laughter ]
So this is --
Because I built walls around it.
I was like, "This is --"
-People don't know.
-I was like,
"This is two different things.
-My meat and my potatoes,
I keep them separate.
-Exactly.
-It's like work and --
I know what you mean now.
-I was just like,
when I came here, I said, "Tha
whole part of my life, dead.
-Dead.
-Dead. Like it didn't happen
-"SNL" who?
-Yeah.
-New phone, who dis?
-New phone, who -- who dis
I remember --
You were out there that day.
'Cause I feel like --
-I know.
-I feel like --
Don't take this the wrong way.
Red carpet
was rolled out for you.
-For me?
-Yeah.
-Hmm.
[ Laughter ]
I'm not gonna dispute that
-Yeah.
I mean, by the way,
I should also stress,
we were at very different part
in our career.
You had --
-Well, I had
red carpet in my contract.
Every --
But you thought a red carpet
was rolled out for me?
-That's a very unfair thin
for me to say.
-No, it's just very interesting.
No, I just think
we should talk about it.
We should unpack it
a little bit more.
-Okay.
-Do you have resentment?
-No, no, no!
-You just remember...
-In fact, it was the opposit
of resentment.
The fact that I got it
when you got it
made it feel like even more --
I, like, couldn't believe that
there was going to be a time
in my life where we had
the same thing at the same time.
-Maybe I did come in, though
I did come in
with an advantage, for sure,
because of "UCB."
I got to do a bunch of
characters on that show.
-Yeah.
-And I had a lot of buddie
on the show, including, you know
my comedy wife, Tina Fey.
-But then, that was a huge -
Like, you were incredibly
generous with that connectio
to everybody else.
You took everybody who didn'
have friends there,
and you were like,
"Come, come, come.
This is a good group of people."
-Yeah.
[ Breathes deeply ]
-It was a long time ago.
-Dude. I don't remember
anything about it.
-Were you nervous
when you auditioned?
-Well, you know this about me,
as evidenced by my participation
in today's broadcast, but when I
get nervous, I get really cocky.
That's, like, my go-to.
It's not always great.
-Mm-hmm.
-And so I think I was --
Which is why it's funny
when you say the red carpet,
'cause I was like, "Oh, no
Did I act like an ass [bleep]?
But when I get nervous,
I double down.
So I think my nerves, I probably
felt them in real time,
but I was acting
like I wasn't nervous at all
I was probably --
I was probably, like,
doing that, like,
fight-or-flight stuff.
-But I didn't see you
at all that day.
-No, I don't think
we even knew each other.
-No, no, no, we didn't.
-In fact, I think we met
for the first time
in Shoemaker's office.
-Yeah.
Shoemaker over there.
Back when he was helpful and..
-Yep.
[ Laughter ]
-Like he's --
-When he had, like --
When he had a job.
-He's changed.
-He has changed?
[ Whispering ]
-Shoemaker's different now
He's very, like,
aggressive now.
-I saw a bunch of
audience members coming in
and he was like, "No!"
-Yeah, we're trying
to have an audience.
And then they show up.
-The audience, they were like,
"We're ready,"
and he was like,
"Get out of here!"
[ Laughter ]
"I'm the audience!"
-"I'm the audience!"
-"I'm the one that laughs!
-And so I said to him,
I'm like, "Then just say -
Then make that policy.
Don't have them
get an audience every day.
He does it every day.
-And then,
he's totally gaslighting me,
'cause he comes up to me,
and he's like,
"Are you excited
for the audience?"
I'm like, "Yeah.
There's an audience?"
and he's like, "No."
[ Laughter ]
And I was like, "Okay."
-Yeah.
-And M. Night is here.
Amazing.
-Yeah.
-And I told M. Night, I'm like
"There's no audience,"
and he's like, "What?"
I'm like, "Yeah."
And he's like,
"Shoemaker told me
there was two audiences."
[ Laughter ]
-And I'm like...
-Shoemaker told me, he's like,
"I'm gonna M. Night M. Night."
He was like --
-He's pulling
an M. Night on him.
-Yeah. He's like, "I'm gonna
throw the twist at M. Night,
see how he likes it."
-He's not gonna like that.
That nomination, too.
That nomination's gonna
cause problems around here
-What, for Alex?
-Yeah.
-Oh, Shoemaker's
gonna be so mad.
[ Laughter ]
-So mad.
-So mad. And, by the way, like
he's like, "I should get it.
I'm like,
"You're not a director."
-Right.
And he's like, he goes --
At one point,
he grabbed my arm really hard,
and I was like, "Ow!"
You know, like, "Hey!
I thought it was a bit."
And I'm like, "Ow!"
And He goes, "I'm the Emmys.
And I go, "You're the Emmys?
[ Laughter ]
He goes, "I'm the Emmys!"
-He does crazy stuff like that
all the time.
-He's like -- "I am legend."
-Yeah.
-He's like, "I am legend."
-And he told us all
he was the mayor.
He goes, "I'm -- I won mayor."
-What?
-And we're like, "For New York?"
[ Laughter ]
And he said, "Yeah." He wa
like, "Yeah, ranked choice."
We're like, "What?"
-What does that mean?
-I don't know. But he's like
"I'm the mayor now."
-And everyone's
gonna go, "Okay."
-Yeah.
-"You're the mayor."
Like, slowly back out
of the room.
-But then,
he, like, keeps it up all day.
He does calls where he's, like
pretending to be the mayor
-Oh, he's like, "Oh, there's
a water pipe burst?"
-Yeah, a lot of that.
-"I better get down there.
I have no audience today."
-Oh.
-Anyway...
-Fascinating.
[ Laughter ]
-Fascinating how people change
-I mean, this has been
a really wild year.
-Yeah. That's true.
We should --
We should forgive that he is -
-Yeah.
-But it's bad.
[ Laughter ]
-[ Laughing ] But it's...
-It is not --
-But it's bad.
-It's not fun to be around
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, my God.
I feel like I'm on drugs.
[ Laughter ]
It's good!
In a good way, in a good way
-Yeah, yeah.
In a good way.
I think -- also, two X's
next to Daniel Day-Lewis.
-Maroon 5!
-Maroon 5 auditioned.
-They auditioned.
[ Laughter ]
-"Making It," which I feel lik
we plugged pretty hard.
-And "Duncanville."
I should plug "Duncanville."
-Oh, it's coming up.
-Oh, sorry.
-Do you want to do it?
-Yeah.
Let's see.
[ Breathes deeply ]
These are cue cards. Okay.
[ Laughter ]
"Making It" airs Thursday nights
at 8:00, here on NBC.
And you can see new episodes
of Amy's
animated series "Duncanville"...
-"Duncanville."
-...Monday nights on Fox.